determina el número de soluciones para
cada una de estas ecuaciones y aquí
tenemos tres ecuaciones pero antes de
que analicemos cada una de estas
ecuaciones recordemos cuando puedes
tener una solución infinitas soluciones
o no haber solución una ecuación va a
tener una solución si puedes resolver
para la variable digamos xy obtener algo
así como x es igual a algo no sé voy a
ponerlo en abstracto x igual aa o podría
ser x igual a 5 x igual a menos 25 x
igual a 10 x igual a pi cualquier valor
cuando se obtiene que x es un valor
específico entonces el sistema tiene una
solución si tú manipulas estas
ecuaciones por procedimientos que sean
válidos por supuesto y al final obtienes
alguna cosa extraña loca así como 3
igual a 5 entonces el sistema no tiene
solución sin solución el resolver una
ecuación es encontrar una x que
satisface la ecuación y si alguien
simplificando la ecuación llegas a un
resultado como 3 igual a sí
te preguntas cuál es el valor de x que
mágicamente hace que 3 sea igual a 5
pues no no hay ningún valor de x que
haga que 3 sea mágicamente igual a 5 no
hay manera de que esto sea verdad sin
importar el valor de x que tú elijas si
llegas un resultado extraño como éste
significa que no hay solución por otro
lado si llegas un resultado como 5 igual
a 5 aquí es coincidencia que estemos
usando el 5 x igual a 5 3 igual a 5 5
igual a 5 pero no tiene que ser
forzosamente el 5 deja de por otro
número para que no pienses que tiene que
ser 5 pongamos 13 igual a 13 cuando
llegas a un resultado donde algo es
exactamente igual a sí mismo sin
importar el valor de x que obtengas es
decir sustituyendo la ecuación cualquier
valor de x vas a obtener este resultado
entonces en este caso se van a obtener
infinitas soluciones después de este
breve resumen analicemos estas
ecuaciones veamos la primera ecuación
restando 2 a ambos lados de la ecuación
para eliminar este 2 vamos a hacer eso
estamos 2 del lado izquierdo y restamos
2 del lado derecho y que nos resulta
menos 7 x + 2 - 12 cancelados
2 - 7x de lado derecho que tenemos 2 x 2
y menos 2 se cancelan menos 9 x ahora
haciendo esta resta del lado derecho nos
queda que menos 7 x es igual a menos 7x
y ya te vas dando cuenta dónde vamos a
llegar pues sin importar el valor de x
menos 7 x es igual a menos 7x así es que
estamos en este caso aunque tú bien
podrías decir oye sal yo no veo algo
como 13 igual a 13 para eso podríamos
hacer algo así como dividir entre menos
7 a ambos lados de la ecuación dividimos
entre menos 7 lado izquierdo menos 7 lo
hecho aunque esto es innecesario pues ya
sabes que menos 7 por un número es
exactamente igual a menos 7 por ese
mismo número pero bueno al hacer la
división nos queda x igual a equis y
ahora podemos restar x ambos lados para
obtener entonces 0 igual a 0 y eso es
verdad para cualquier valor de x que tú
elijas siempre se lo va a ser igual a 0
y todos estos pasos son válidos para
cualquier valor de x que elijamos así es
que esta ecuación en particular tiene
una infinidad de soluciones un número
infinito
de soluciones veamos ahora esta ecuación
del medio está la voy a hacer diferente
voy a sumar las x del lado derecho voy a
sumar 2 x con menos 9 x que nos queda
del lado izquierdo no hemos hecho nada
nos queda menos 7 x + 3 que es igual a 2
x menos 9 x es igual a menos 7 x menos 7
x más 2 ahora sumemos déjame hacerlo
mejor en el color verde
y lo tenemos más dos en verde sumamos
ahora 7x a ambos lados de la ecuación
del lado izquierdo menos 7 x 7 x se
cancela nos queda solo 3 y del lado
derecho también menos 7 x con 7 x se
cancelan y nos queda simplemente 2 es
sumado 7 x del lado izquierdo y es
sumado 7 x del lado derecho pero que
obtuvimos obtuvimos 3 igualados pero
este resultado es imposible sin importar
el valor de x que elijamos así es que
estamos en el caso de la ecuación que no
tiene solución así es que esta es una
ecuación sin solución no existe una x en
el universo que cumpla con esta ecuación
ahora veamos la tercera ecuación
empecemos restando 3 a ambos lados
quiero eliminar este 3 así es que el
lado izquierdo se cancelan 3 y menos 3
nos queda menos 7 x y esto es igual a
más 2 y menos 3 o menos 1 nos queda 2x
menos 1
ahora podemos restar 2 x ambos lados
restamos 2x a ambos lados para obtener
entonces del lado izquierdo nos queda
menos 9 x el lado derecho se cancelan
estos términos nos queda menos 1
dividiendo entre menos 9 ambos lados
llegamos ya a la solución de la ecuación
x igual a 1 b no estamos en este caso de
aquí encontramos explícitamente una
solución x igual a un noveno que cumple
con esta ecuación así es que esta
ecuación de aquí tiene exactamente una
solución